Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter One, Episode 1, Part Two.
Now we come to the next big turning point: the Reformation, the Swedish wars, and the introduction of absolute monarchy, roughly fifteen hundred to seventeen hundred.
With the Reformation in 1536, Protestantism was introduced in Denmark.
At the same time, the king's power became much greater.
The church was placed under the king, instead of under the Pope, and the king took over the church's property.
In the Middle Ages, the Danish church was part of the Catholic church, which belonged directly under the Pope in Rome.
So the church in Denmark was relatively independent of the king.
It was a rich and powerful institution.
But around the year 1500 its power was threatened by several movements that wanted to reform the church.
They were called Protestant.
One of them was led by the German monk Martin Luther.
The revolt led large parts of Northern Europe to break with the Pope.
Instead, independent Protestant churches were founded in close cooperation with local kings and princes.
Martin Luther's ideas came to Denmark in the 1520s.
It was especially the priest Hans Tausen, who lived from fourteen ninety-four to fifteen sixty-one, who spread them.
Their central point was that you could only achieve salvation by believing, not by doing good deeds or by buying indulgences.
In several Danish towns the discussions grew into popular resistance against the rich and powerful Catholic church.
In 1534 civil war broke out in Denmark between the Catholic leaders of the church and the supporters of Protestantism.
Under the leadership of Christian the Third, who reigned from fifteen thirty-six to fifty-nine, the Protestants won in 1536.
The same year, the Reformation was formally carried out.
Denmark became a Protestant country, and the king removed the Catholic bishops.
The Danish church now belonged to the king instead of the Pope.
And the church's political power became much smaller.
The Catholic church had owned very large values and a lot of land, and now the king took all of it over.
At the same time, he closed the monasteries.
Until then the language of the church had been Latin, which few understood.
Martin Luther believed everyone should have access to Christianity in their own language.
So the Reformation meant that the Bible was translated into Danish, and church services and hymn singing from then on took place only in Danish.
"Christian the Third's Bible", the first translation of the Bible into Danish, came out in 1550.
The Reformation also meant that only the king could appoint priests and bishops.
In this way the church could be used to strengthen royal power, and, with the translated Bible, to spread a common Danish written language to every corner of the kingdom.
In the longer term, the Reformation was of decisive importance for Danish history, because it tied state, church, language and population closely together.
In the short term, it became the beginning of a strong state power, which in 1660 to 61 developed into royal absolutism.
Now, a king who left a huge mark: Christian the Fourth, who reigned from fifteen eighty-eight to sixteen forty-eight.
He was king for almost sixty years, longer than anyone else in Danish history, and he is one of the most significant kings.
Like other kings of his time, he had a great interest in art and architecture, and was behind a long series of buildings, especially in and around the capital, Copenhagen, in the first half of the 1600s.
Among the well-known buildings he had built: Frederiksborg Castle at Hillerød, the Copenhagen Stock Exchange, Rosenborg Castle, and the Round Tower, Rundetårn, in Copenhagen.
He also founded several new towns, mostly outside present-day Denmark: Kristianstad in Skåne, Kristiansand in Norway, and Kristiania, which is now called Oslo, the capital of Norway.
But Christian the Fourth's reign was also marked by lost wars and lost land.
When he took over the government, Denmark dominated the Baltic area, but Sweden also had big ambitions there.
The balance of power changed markedly when, in the years sixteen twenty-five to twenty-nine, Christian pulled Denmark into the Thirty Years' War, a great European war that was mainly fought in Germany, from sixteen eighteen to forty-eight.
The king suffered a big military defeat in 1626, and when Denmark withdrew from the war in 1629, Sweden had become the leading power in the Baltic area.
The poor relationship with Sweden continued for the rest of Christian the Fourth's reign.
In 1643 Denmark was attacked by Sweden, and in 1645 Denmark had to give up, among other things, the province of Halland for thirty years, the island of Gotland in the Baltic Sea, and parts of Norway to Sweden.
When Christian the Fourth died in 1648, Denmark was a country in deep crisis, and Sweden's superiority would last for the rest of the 1600s.
In the years sixteen fifty-seven to sixty, Denmark was at war with Sweden again, in two rounds.
In the first, Swedish troops had marched up from a war in Poland and occupied Jutland.
Then came the extremely cold winter of sixteen fifty-seven to fifty-eight, when a thick layer of ice formed on the sea around Denmark.
The Danish fleet was therefore cut off from defending the Danish islands.
The Swedes, on the other hand, could walk across the ice to Funen, and then to Langeland, Lolland and Zealand, and they conquered large parts of Denmark.
At the peace treaty in Roskilde, the Peace of Roskilde, in 1658, Denmark had to give up Skåne, Halland and Blekinge for good, and several Norwegian areas, to Sweden.
Bornholm was also ceded to Sweden in the same treaty.
But the island's population quickly staged an uprising and overthrew the Swedish rule, so that Bornholm became Danish again.
Later the same year, the Swedish king regretted not having conquered all of Denmark.
War came again, and the Swedes besieged Copenhagen, which means they surrounded the city to make it surrender.
But with help from the Netherlands, the Danish capital managed to withstand the siege, and the Swedes did not conquer more Danish areas.
They also had to accept that Bornholm would remain Danish.
But losing so much land had big consequences for Denmark.
A large loss of population, of fertile farmland, of valuable trade, and of a long coastline on the Baltic Sea.
And Denmark no longer controlled both sides of the Øresund, the Sound, which is the entrance and exit of the Baltic Sea.
After that, Denmark was no longer a power in Northern Europe.
And this is how the stage was set for the great change.
After the lost wars to Sweden and the country's poor economy, the demand grew among the population to abolish the special privileges of the nobility.
The nobility made up less than one percent of the population.
They were magnates, typically landowners, and they had a series of privileges.
For example, they did not have to pay tax.
They could choose who would be the new king when a king died.
And with a håndfæstning they could force the new king to share power with them.
In return for their privileges, they had to give military support to the king in time of war.
In October 1660, King Frederik the Third, who reigned from sixteen forty-eight to seventy, introduced that the nobility would from now on pay tax, among other things to rebuild the country after the wars against Sweden.
The nobility, which had not been much help during the war, also had to accept that royal power would from now on automatically be inherited from the reigning king to his nearest heir.
The king used his new power, in sixteen sixty to sixty-one, to introduce a new form of government in Denmark, called absolutism, "enevælde".
The king now governed the country completely alone.
He could appoint officials, introduce laws and collect taxes without first asking anyone's permission.
A real central state administration emerged, and a permanent army controlled by the king.
And as the only absolute monarchy in Europe, Denmark got in 1665 a constitution that was formulated and written down.
This law was called the King's Law, Kongeloven.
It established, first and foremost, that the king had almost unlimited power.
It set only very few limits on what the king could do.
He was not allowed to give up his absolute power, neither wholly nor partly.
He was also not allowed to divide the kingdom between his children, but had to let everything pass to the heir to the throne.
And finally, he had to belong to the Protestant church, which had been created with the Reformation in the 1500s, based on Martin Luther's teaching.
The King's Law remained the foundation of the king's absolute power all the way until the first democratic constitution in 1849.
And that is exactly where we pick up the story in Episode Two.
Before we go, here is the quick recap for your exam.
Denmark has existed as an independent state for more than a thousand years.
Harald Blåtand, around 965, is regarded as the first king of all Denmark, and the Jelling stone is Denmark's baptismal certificate.
Odin, Thor and Freja are gods of the old Asatro religion.
Svend Tveskæg conquered England in 1013.
About three thousand churches had been built by 1250, in the Catholic Middle Ages.
Margrete the First created the Kalmar Union in 1397.
Christian the Fourth built Rosenborg and the Round Tower.
The first håndfæstning was in 1282, the Jutland Law in 1241, the Black Death around 1350, and the Kalmar Union in 1397, dissolved in 1523.
The Reformation came in 1536, Christian the Third's Bible in 1550, and the Peace of Roskilde in 1658, which gave Skåne, Halland and Blekinge to Sweden.
The Reformation gave the king power over the church, and absolutism gave the king even more power.
Absolutism began in 1660 to 61, and the King's Law dates from 1665.
See you in Episode Two.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
How did the relationship between the king and the church change as a result of the Reformation in the 1500s?
Option A: The king got less power over the church.
Option B: The king got more power over the church.
[DA] Hvordan ændrede forholdet mellem kongen og kirken sig som følge af reformationen i 1500-tallet?  A: Kongen fik mindre magt over kirken  |  B: Kongen fik mere magt over kirken
The answer is B: The king got more power over the church.
It appeared in the May 2023 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Kongen fik mere magt over kirken
Question 2.
What did the Reformation in Denmark in 1536 involve?
Option A: Introduction of a democratic constitution.
Option B: The transition from Catholic to Protestant Christianity.
Option C: Abolition of the king's exclusive right to trade with foreign countries.
[DA] Hvad indebar reformationen i Danmark i 1536?  A: Indførelsen af en demokratisk grundlov  |  B: Overgangen fra katolsk til protestantisk kristendom  |  C: Ophævelse af kongens eneret på at handle med udlandet
The answer is B: The transition from Catholic to Protestant Christianity.
It appeared in the May 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Overgangen fra katolsk til protestantisk kristendom
Question 3.
Which king is behind the building of, among other things, the Round Tower and Rosenborg Castle in Copenhagen?
Option A: Christian the Fourth.
Option B: Christian the Seventh.
Option C: Christian the Tenth.
[DA] Hvilken konge står bag opførelsen af blandt andet Rundetårn og Rosenborg Slot i København?  A: Christian den 4.  |  B: Christian den 7.  |  C: Christian den 10.
The answer is A: Christian the Fourth.
It appeared in the November 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Christian den 4.
Question 4.
Which wars involving Denmark were fought in the 1600s?
Option A: The Schleswig Wars.
Option B: The England Wars.
Option C: The Swedish Wars.
[DA] Hvilke krige med dansk deltagelse blev udkæmpet i 1600-tallet?  A: De Slesvigske Krige  |  B: Englandskrigene  |  C: Svenskekrigene
The answer is C: The Swedish Wars.
It appeared in the November 2021 and November 2023 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Svenskekrigene
Question 5.
Which territory did Denmark lose to Sweden in the middle of the 1600s?
Option A: Halland.
Option B: Småland.
Option C: Värmland.
[DA] Hvilket af følgende landområder mistede Danmark til Sverige i midten af 1600-tallet?  A: Halland  |  B: Småland  |  C: Värmland
The answer is A: Halland.
It appeared in the June 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Halland
Question 6.
Which territories did Denmark lose in 1658?
Option A: Skåne, Halland and Blekinge.
Option B: The Shetland and Orkney Islands.
Option C: The West Indian Islands.
[DA] Hvilke af følgende landområder mistede Danmark i 1658?  A: Skåne, Halland og Blekinge  |  B: Shetlandsøerne og Orkneyøerne  |  C: De Vestindiske Øer
The answer is A: Skåne, Halland and Blekinge.
It appeared in the June 2022 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Skåne, Halland og Blekinge
Question 7.
What was the result of the war against Sweden in 1657 to 58?
Option A: Denmark lost Skåne.
Option B: Denmark conquered Skåne.
[DA] Hvad blev resultatet af krigen mod Sverige i 1657-58?  A: Danmark mistede Skåne  |  B: Danmark erobrede Skåne
The answer is A: Denmark lost Skåne.
It appeared in the June 2026 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Danmark mistede Skåne
Question 8.
Who gained more power with the absolute monarchy introduced in Denmark in 1660 to 61?
Option A: The nobility.
Option B: The church.
Option C: The king.
[DA] Hvem fik mere magt med enevælden, der blev indført i Danmark i 1660-61?  A: Adelen  |  B: Kirken  |  C: Kongen
The answer is C: The king.
It appeared in the November 2023 and May 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Kongen
That's the end of this part.
Well done.